madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
t nous allons développer dans cette
édition le veto du gouvernement français
au rachat de l'entreprise orangina par
coca cola la déception des salariés mais
dominique strauss kahn laisse la porte
ouverte
manifestation des enseignants à paris à
l'appel du principal syndicat une
mobilisation en demi teinte avec comme
revendication davantage de moyens aux
etats-unis le congrès a voté tout à
l'heure la diffusion sur les chaînes de
télévision du témoignage vidéo du bill
clinton diffusion à partir de lundi
prochain
réactions dans ce journal de notre
invité anthony blinken qui est
conseiller à la maison blanche à la
veille de la grande de techno parade à
paris qui doit rassembler des dizaines
de milliers de personnes
découverte de la culture technique aux
états unis dans un climat délétère où la
vie privée des responsables de la nation
s'étalent désormais dans la presse comme
autant d'armes politique
le congrès américain a donné son feu
vert pour que la vidéo du témoignage de
bill clinton dans la sphère libinski
soit diffusé à la télévision philippe
gassot le président de la commission
judiciaire vient de le confirmer les
enregistrements vidéo du président
seront présentés au public même si ça
n'est pas conforme du temps du côté
démocrate au règlement pour des raisons
techniques les américains devront
attendre encore quelques heures pour
suivre la déposition comme si lisier
terre d'un président pas toujours à son
avantage en général côté démocrate
on ne voulait rien révélé du tout côté
républicain on voulait laisser sortir un
maximum d'informations dans les rangs
démocrates
on est choqué cette procédure a été la
plus partisane à laquelle j'ai jamais eu
à participer
de plus aujourd'hui la maison blanche
est accusé d'avoir monté de toutes
pièces la sphère ride les américains
grâce à internet on appris qu'il y avait
du jekyll chez hays l'incorruptible
présidents républicains de la commission
judiciaire qui doit statuer sur les
fautes de bill clinton a eu il y a
trente ans une aventure extraconjugale
agitée
est ce la photo à l'appui les
républicains ont mis le fbi a et sur les
fuites mais ils ont déjà une petite idée
des coupables
nous avons de bonnes raisons de croire
que les instigateurs ont accès au salon
ovale
l'enquète dira peut-être ce qui se cache
derrière tout cela cependant bill
clinton a senti hier soir le vent du
boulet pour la première fois depuis la
sortie du rapport
il a été bien sûr soutenu par ses
partisans mais aussi copieusement hué
dans les rues de là très vertueuse ville
de boston
certains prennent cela pour un signe la
crainte des démocrates c'est que les
bandes vidéo présentée au public
américain n'affecte le seul soutien dont
bénéficie actuellement le président
clinton à savoir sa position dans les
sondages
mias l'une des questions que nous allons
poser en direct de washington à anthony
blinken bonsoir vous êtes conseiller à
la maison blanche
j'imagine que vous réagissez avec une
extrême vigueur à la diffusion de la
vidéo du témoignage du président mais
d'abord ma première question ce que les
démocrates qui avaient voté pour la
publication du rapport à la majorité se
sont ils suffisamment battu cette fois
ci je pense que ils se sont fort bien
battu mais finalement là n'est pas la
question
pour nous le peuple américain ne
s'intéresse pas du tout à ces détails
c'est dommage que les détails on était
donc encore plus accentuée dans le
public avec la vidéo qui va sortir mais
tout ce que nous entendons du peuple
américain
tout ce que nous voyons dans les
sondages c'est qu'il ne s'intéresse pas
à cette affaire il ne s'intéresse pas
aux détails mais au contraire ils
s'intéressent au travail à l'agenda du
président milliken le congrès ce sont
des parlementaires qui représente le
peuple américain malgré tout donc on a
du mal à vous croire
écoutez le congrès est obligé et devra
faire son travail c'est-à-dire étudier
les faits qui sont devant le congrès et
décider quelle pas à prendre
prochainement nous espérons tous
vivement que le congrès agira rapidement
et qu'on en finira avec un dossier qui
n'intéresse pas le peuple américain en
effet alors il apparaît que bill clinton
réunis tous les jours une équipe pour
approcher une équipe scandale qui
cherchent les ripostes possibles
vous avez donc jusqu'à lundi avant la
diffusion quelle carte vous reste-t-il
écoutez le président évidemment passe du
temps sur ce problème et se réunit en
équipe tout comme il se réunit la
plupart de la journée avec ses équipes
en politique étrangère en politique
domestique pour les dossiers qui
concernent vraiment le peuple américain
donc le président vous savez ira aux
nations unies cette semaine où il fera
un discours très important sur le
terrorisme où il rencontrera son
homologue pakistanais et pour le
problème de la prolifération des armes
nucléaires en asie où il verra son
homologue japonais pour les questions
d'économie mondiale ça c'est le travail
du président et c'est sur cela qu'ils se
concentrent on a bien compris que
c'était sa position et sa défense on a
quand même le sentiment que la politique
se fait désormais aux états unis dans le
caniveau
diriez-vous qu'on est en train
d'assister à une sorte de mccarthysme
sexuelle de chacun peur pour sa vie
privée au fond dans ce qu'on voit c'est
que dans toutes les sondages dans tout
ce que nous entendons le taux de
popularité du président et du travail et
de son action reste très haut pour une
raison très simple c'est que le pays se
porte bien sous la présidence de bill
clinton
nous avons le chômage à 4,5 pour cent
nous avons un nombre record de travail
qui ont été créés ces derniers mois nous
avons un roc un nombre record
d'américains propriétaire de la maison
et nous avons malgré les graves
problèmes dans le monde
la paye quand même qui règne pour les
américains ainsi donc qu'il n'est pas
une surprise les américains se préoccupe
surtout de comment le président va
continuer à agir sur les dossiers qu'il
est consciente dans leur vie actuelle
mais ce week-end on a quand même
l'impression que vous êtes en campagne
électorale car les états unis sont en
pleine campagne électorale
est ce qu'au fond pour pêcher des voix
en tente de mettre à mort le président
est-ce que ça c'est votre action c'est
sûr que nous sommes en campagne
électorale nous avons nos élections en
novembre
et c'est justement pour cela que ce
dossier prend encore plus d'envergure sa
loi de vue dans un contexte politique
mais tout ce que le président peut faire
finalement c'est évidemment se défendre
dans ce dossier et se défendre sur les
faits et deuxièmement continuer l'action
pour lequel il a été voté deux fois la
maison blanche c'est ça son travail et
c'est ce qu'il fera dans les semaines et
les mois à venir
merci monsieur dean cain d'avoir répondu
en direct de washington a new question
en france la déception du patron
orangina y de ses salariés après le
refus du gouvernement qui s'est donc
opposé au rachat de la société par le
géant américain coca cola dominique
strauss kahn s'est dit malgré tout
ouverts à de nouvelles propositions
pascal golomer ian gicquel atlanta le
siège de la coca cola company c'est
d'ici qui était parti il annonce du
rachat d'orangina en décembre dernier
neuf mois plus tard les négociateurs
reviennent de france bredouille
le gouvernement français a dit non voilà
à penser que une année passe pour
occuper trop de ce que disait le conseil
label durance si c'est ça ils se sont
trompés
mais c'est son prêt à revenir une
proposition qui respecte se peut qu'on
sait la couture à saborder
alors on arrive à aller au bout la porte
reste donc ouverte
coca cola dans un communiqué laconique
dit étudier les différentes options qui
se présentent à elle sans plus de
détails tout le différend porte en fait
sur la vente dans les cafés restaurants
et autres distributeurs automatiques
tout ce qu'on appelle le hors domicile
orangina en bouteille et distribue
actuellement les produits pepsi destinés
à la restauration
et si le grand concurrent de coca dans
le monde si orangina tombe dans le giron
de coca plus question évidemment de
vendre du pepsi et la gamme de coca cola
pourrait se retrouver en situation de
quasi monopole dans les cafés et
restaurants avec les risques de hausse
des prix que cela comporte
le gouvernement français demandez donc à
coca de confier la distribution
d'orangina dans ce secteur à une autre
entreprise indépendante pendant dix ans
coca a refusé l'accord le gouvernement a
refusé la vente le vendeur pernod ricard
comptait recevoir un chèque de 5
milliards de francs
il devra attendre jusqu'à deux minutes
nous pensions que la réponse allait être
favorable d'où ma déception
le groupe dit ne pas chercher d'autres
repreneurs pour l'instant pas de quoi
rassurer les salariés d'orangina qui
avait obtenu des américains la garantie
de l'emploi jusqu'à fin 2012 balle est
désormais dans le camp de coca cola mais
la petite bouteille ronde française n'a
pas encore pris l'accent américain
là après la dégringolade de l'action
alcatel hier de mémoire de boursier on
n'avait jamais enregistré par une chute
le gendarme des opérations de bourse la
cob a ouvert une enquête
alors que le président d'alcatel tenter
de tout faire pour rassurer les milieux
financiers
jean-paul chapelle et philippe turpault
la descente aux enfers continue pour
alcatel après le krach d'hier moins 2,8
pour cent aujourd'hui panique à la
bourse de paris les coupe circuit sont
mises en route à nouveau pour freiner la
chute sans succès à madrid devant de
racheter des titres pendant un certain
temps afin que l'information soit
disponible et diffusées auprès de
l'ensemble des intervenants dans un
communiqué le pdg d'alcatel lui-même se
déclare surpris par la réaction du
marché
il redit sa confiance dans le plan
stratégique de l'entreprise et il
annonce un programme significatif de
rachat d'actions d'alcatel ultime
tentative pour regagner la confiance des
marchés
trop tard les investisseurs anglo saxons
ont décidé de punir à leucate et les
américains font pas de sentiment qu'en
dix ans on lui demande une valeur quand
ils n'y croient plus ils vendent
massivement
ils vendent sans passer des mythes de
prix et il vendre à tout prix ce sont
eux qui ont enfoncé des coups mais il
faut pas oublier que ce souhait qui
avait emballé la place de paris depuis
début d'année le titre alcatel a valu
plus de 1400 francs il voue aujourd'hui
un peu plus de 500 francs massacré
l'action aura du mal à retrouver sa
crédibilité
tout ça pour une petite phrase prononcée
hier par le pdg serge tchuruk lors de la
présentation des résultats c'est clair
aujourd'hui que il y avait une attente
dans son considérable en résultat
opérationnel de pour alcatel cette année
je préviens les marchés que tel ne sera
pas le cas pour eux un nombre de raisons
crise en asie crise en russie
concurrence accrue le résultat du 1er
semestre atteint 2,3 milliards de francs
au lieu des 4 milliards promis les fonds
de pension américains ont le sentiment
d'avoir été trompés ils ne sont pas
prêts de pardonner au deuxième jour du
procès de florence rey devant la cour
d'assises de paris l'audition très
attendue du médecin qui se trouvait là
bord du taxi lors de la prise d'otages
par le couple remo pain compte rendu
d'audience de munich vers d'ailleurs
comment interpréter ce v de la victoire
est simplement parce que le
tord monier se dit miraculé c'est la
remercier
une conformation crédit un petit peu
notre lutte
tiendrai le même discours il ya quatre
ans absolument le docteur georges
monnier était dans le taxi que florence
rey et audry maupin ont intercepté le 4
octobre 1994 pour assurer leur fuite
après leur premier méfait
quatre ans après il reste imprégné de
ces images audry maupin qui met son
pistolet sur la tempe du taxi lui qui
essaye d'établir un dialogue pour
dédramatiser
florence rey qui lui répond pas de
philosophie docteur freud le témoin se
souvient avoir vu florence rey recharger
son fusil à pompe avec sang froid et
maîtrise il se souvient aussi des mots
de l'accusé alors qu'il tentait de
s'enfuir vient où je te t-il
ce n'était pas des délinquants de base
ont utile et bel amour viadeo qui au
delà des mots il vienne espèce de rejet
de la société de voir au vrai moi pas
tirer instantanément comme ça / / / le
sur les policiers qui étaient
complètement ahurie images et je regarde
et le regard ahuri des policiers qui
venaient d'être percuté par taxi vous
savez instantanément il a tiré dessus
alors que c'était c'était du délire
idéologique plus humblement
cette détermination dans les mots dans
les actes les deux policiers brachial
après fourrière de pantin ne sont pas
prêts de l'oublier
ils nous ont traités de sales flics se
souvient l'un j'ai cru qu'ils allaient
nous tuer dit l'autre nous retrouvons en
direct c'est dominique verdeilhan quelle
a été l'attitude la défense de florence
rey aujourd'hui au cours de l'audience
technique après le pardon les remords
les larmes d'hier il faut pour florence
rey affronter seules les témoins et le
box doit paraître bien grand pour
florence rey car à chacune des questions
posées elle parle d'audry maupin si elle
à lui jacques mesrine l'ex ennemi public
numéro un
c'est ptet pour pouvoir en discuter avec
son ami si elle a acheté une arme c'est
parce que maupin voulait un fusil nov
c'est maupin qui a eu l'idée de
s'attaquer à la préfourrière de pantin
c'est maupin toujours qui a braqué les
armes aux policiers alors à
l'adolescente en larmes d'hier succède
aujourd'hui la jeune fille sous
influence certes les témoins le confirme
florence rey était toujours en retrait
derrière audry maupin
seulement voilà personne n'est venu dire
qu en 25 minutes florence rey a tout
fait pour stopper cette défense aux
enfers merci et demi vers d'ailleurs
hier soir policiers du commissariat de
mantes-la-jolie a été tué alors qu'il
intervenait avec cinq de ses collègues
dans une affaire familiale serge roux
est âgé de 30 ans a été mortellement
blessé jean olharan ans philippe
visseyrias c'est vraisemblablement avec
cette arme un fusil de chasse que sergio
et gardiens de la paix au commissariat
de mantes la jolie a été abattu hier
soir dans ce quartier de gargenville
dans les yvelines s'est rejouée était
âgé de 30 ans mariée il était aussi père
d'une petite fille de 2 ans cet après
midi les hommes de l'identité judiciaire
ont tenté de reconstituer le scénario du
drame
appelé par un témoin qui avait entendu
des coups de feu serge roux et cinq de
ses collègues sont arrivés vers 20h30
hier soir aux abords d'un préfabriqué
habitée par des gens du voyage
sédentarisés
quand ils se sont rapprochés du bungalow
subitement de la haie de troènes kyi qui
a été à côté a surgi un jeune homme de
24 ans armé d'un fusil qui a tiré une
balle de gros calibre sur le gardien le
plus proche qui était d'environ trois
mètres et la balle est passée au dessus
du gilet pare balles sous l'aisselle et
la provoquer sa mort quasiment inspecté
le meurtrier présumé blessé à la tête
sera rapidement maîtrisé le jeune homme
était connu dans le quartier pour être
très turbulent et porté sur la boisson
placé en garde à vue par le parquet de
versailles il sera mis en examen samedi
pour meurtre au commissariat de mantes
la jolie
le drapeau est en berne jean-jack
queyranne assistera lundi prochain à la
levée du corps du policier
la grève dans l'éducation nationale
différé de 15 jours pour ne pas gêner la
rentrée un mouvement lancé par la fsu la
principale organisation syndicale
diversement suivi manifestation à paris
avec comme revendication davantage de
moyens
une façon d'assurer l'avenir de nos
enfants pouvait-on lire sur les
banderoles nathalie mois-un an nathalie
gallet contre la précarité et pour
l'emploi public
quinze jours après la rentrée ce mot
d'ordre n'a pas réussi à mobiliser
pleinement les personnels enseignants
ils étaient quelques milliers dans la
manifestation parisienne pour réclamer
plus de moyens
s'il n'y a pas la quantité c'est à dire
des moyens à ses professeurs à des
surveillants un personnel non enseignant
le secrétariat lui l'argent ya pas de
qualité dans l'ensemble de la majorité
gouvernementale ont dit que voulez-vous
faire de l'école comment pouvez vous
nous demandez de progresser dans la
scolarisation et la réussite de tous les
jeunes sans vous donner ce dont nous
avons besoin sans écouter toutes les
propositions que les collections et pour
se faire entendre dans cette école de la
banlieue parisienne
huit institutrices sur 14 faisait grève
ce matin les plus déçus n'était pas
forcément ceux qu'on croit pourquoi
enfin aller à l'école comprend des
choses je pense que c'est tant mieux
pour eux s'ils arrivent à obtenir ce
qu'ils veulent et c'est tant pis pour
moi pour nous pour les parents et ce
n'est pas fini à l'appel du snes les
enseignants du second degré seront
également en grève jeudi prochain en
corrèze plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de retraités agricoles se sont retrouvés
dans le centre de la ville de tulle dont
le député françois hollande dans cette
préfecture de la corrèze fief de jacques
chirac les manifestants demandent une
augmentation substantielle de leur
retraite pour arriver à joindre les deux
bouts
peut-on demander à ceux qui touchent le
revenu minimum d'insertion rmi de faire
en retour un travail d'intérêt général à
cette question que pose une nouvelle
fois le président du conseil général des
pyrénées-orientales
la réponse sera demain dans la rue après
midi trois associations de chômeurs
organise une manifestation nationale
contre ce qu'ils appellent la notion de
travail obligatoire vers une gaglione
pascal pons ici on aurait parfois tu que
du vieil électroménager on s'occupe
également de remettre en état les hommes
ce qui touche le rmi et veulent
retrouver le chemin de l'emploi
depuis deux ans que ce chantier école
existe cinq personnes seulement ne sont
pas restés refusant la discipline de
l'entreprise
les autres ont volontiers troqué leur
rmi contre un contrat ici il acquiert
une formation et travail 20 ou 30 heures
par semaine payées au smic
on a quelque chose entre les mains
s'occupait déjà c'est pas qu'ils sont
immenses et qu'on est motivé on a besoin
de travailler
c'est le besoin de travailler le contact
c'est très important parce qu'un vrai
contrat ça veut dire j'ai un contrat de
travail
j'ai des horaires à respecter je fais
vraiment une tâche qui ne t'a chute il
est pour moi et pour les autres qui
m'amènera vers un vrai emploi jouent
d'autres même si effectivement tout le
monde n'aura pas un emploi à la sortie
je crois qu'il faut pas non plus que ce
soit un leurre pour que le rmi ne soit
pas considérée comme une simple
allocations mais comme une porte ouverte
vers l'insertion
le président du conseil général a décidé
de systématiser les propositions
d'activités pour les 15000 rmistes des
pyrénées-orientales iliad d3 et des
devoirs dans la vie le droit d'un de nos
concitoyens qui se trouvent dans cette
situation sociale très difficile champ
droit c'est d'être aidés par la société
son devoir c'est de participer à cette
juste et les travaux ou les formations
effectuées pourraient être rémunérés en
plus du rmi comme le permettra bientôt
la loi sur l'exclusion mais ça ne
satisfait pas toute la population
concernée certains parlent de st lô sous
travail obligatoire le travail les 10 il
est là mais simplement on va employer
les gens à faire à sous-travail
sous-payés souris numéro est resté
toujours rmistes bien des zones d'ombré
subsistent dans le projet du conseil
général y aura-t-il des sanctions à
l'encontre des rmistes qui refuseraient
les activités proposées
ce n'est pas exclu en début d'après midi
lionel jospin s'est rendu au chevet de
jean pierre chevènement à l'hôpital du
val-de-grâce répondant à la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur c'est ce qu'a
indiqué tout à l'heure un communiqué de
matignon
en politique les regards convergent vers
toulon où doit se dérouler dimanche le
premier tour de l'élection législative
partielle
un test électoral notamment pour la
droite qui espère à travers son candidat
marc bell effacer les échecs successifs
dans cette région
l'importance de ce scrutin se mesure au
nombre de leaders politiques qui ont
fait le déplacement tant à droite qu'à
gauche une élection qui se joue sur le
fil puisque en mai dernier il n'y avait
que 33 voix qui séparait la candidate
socialiste à celles du front national
michaël darmon
yann streiff
à chacune de ses visites de soutien à
toulon nicolas sarkozy a le sourire un
peu plus crispé
car ici la droite est affolée par les
résultats du front national au point
parfois de vouloir copier c'est m cette
fois ci le nouveau candidat investi et
mark bell hostiles au fn mais la droite
toulonnaise continuent de se déchirer
pendant la campagne il leur est alors au
numéro deux du rpr que l'humour pour
faire passer ses messages
on vous savez il ya une tradition qui
fait que c'est plus agréable d'aller
dans les endroits où il n'y a pas de
problème que d'aller dans les endroits
ya des difficultés aux marques moins
chères marque là je suis tranquille s'il
fallait aller que dans les endroits où
il n'y a pas de problème on resterait
souvent rue de lille odette casanova la
candidate sortante de la gauche
plurielle a choisi elle de coller à
l'image du gouvernement pas moins de
quatre ministres ont donc défilé en
l'espace de dix jours dans les rues de
toulon cette roma s'est depuis trois ans
et se passe rien
avec tous les ans rassemble en ont ras
le bol c'est malheureusement inévitable
avec l'image des miss pay tv dans la vie
et pour les habitants l'exercice
consiste à deviner qui est la vedette du
jour
quant à la candidate du front national
elle a choisi d'affronter tulou tout
seul avec une petite équipe
le marché en sortie des codes la
campagne de sandrine chevalier se veut
centrer sur les questions locales
sans vedette à ses côtés
moi j'en peu les fosses et vraiment je
crois que madame casanova fait une
grosse erreur en faisant descendre les
ministres qui n'ont pas la cote
je positive pour la troisième fois en un
peu plus d'un an les toulonnais vont se
rendre aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés et il semble lassé par cette
campagne électorale ininterrompue le
président du rpr philippe séguin
paraphrase la fable de la fontaine pour
qualifier l'action du gouvernement un
gouvernement cigales qui pourraient se
retrouver dépourvu jean baptiste auprès
d'ali daniel levy le rpr attaque la
dernière ligne droite du renouvellement
de ses instances
en décembre ce sera l'élection du
président par les militants et pour
l'instant
philippe séguin ne dit pas encore s'il
sera candidat mais en attendant il faut
bien remobilisée et dans les embarras de
la droite on pense avoir trouvé la
solution au rpr il faut positiver c'est
effectivement
situation qui n'est pas sain pour le
conditionnel jeu convention allait pas
simple on peut pour la majorité
l'opposition a reçu un coup sur la tête
elle a été un peu je dirais puncher
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec un
mouvement politique qui sort de sa
déprime mais il lui reste à s'organiser
à tenter de se faire entendre en
accusant la gauche de se servir du front
national par exemple et en critiquant la
politique économique du gouvernement
le gouvernement a joué les cigales
distribuant de 6 de leur imposant les 35
heures les 350 mille emplois publics
déguisés ils risquent de se retrouver
fort dépourvue quand la bise sera venue
la critique d'un côté la démonstration
d'unité de démocratie interne de l'autre
le rpr réfléchi sur lui même c'est une
stratégie se hâter lentement
c'est décidé la fusion critère des
moeurs a été approuvé cet après midi par
les américains et dans les heures qui
viennent sans tenir aucun doute par les
allemands un mariage qui fera de ce
nouveau groupe le troisième constructeur
automobile mondial luc bastien rémy
passionnés
un spectacle déjà à l'américaine pour
présenter une allemande de la nouvelle
mercedes classe s
en fait cette voiture sera la dernière
100% daimler-benz c'était il ya moins de
deux semaines à stuttgart
le directoire poser fièrement auprès de
ce modèle le plus haut de gamme de la
marque
mais le constructeur allemand a décidé
de se marier avec la belle américaine
chrysler
l'un et l'autre fusionnent pour vivre
sous la même étoile le plus gros mariage
de l'industrie automobile
cela va nous permettre d'aborder de
nouveaux segments de marché qui n'était
pas ouvert à la marque mercedes-benz
parallèlement il nous allons avoir
davantage de faire bénéficier de la
technologie mercedes benz un marché
beaucoup plus grand avec une plume bien
plus important ce sont donc deux
sociétés très fort qui se rejoignent et
c'est très positif pour les deux
sociétés mises en commun tellement
positif que le nouveau groupe
daimlerchrysler pense pouvoir réaliser 8
milliards et demi de francs d'économies
dès la première année des économies
rendues possibles grâce à un pouvoir
d'achat renforcé pour donner leur accord
officiel les actionnaires américains
étaient réunis aujourd'hui dans le
michigan et les allemands images cultes
gare de part et d'autre on jure qu'il
n'y aura ni fermeture d'usiné ni
licenciement
même si certains en doutent le nouvel
ensemble comptera plus de 430 mille
salariés et se hissera au troisième rang
mondial des constructeurs automobiles
chacun gardera son identité au sein du
même groupe les deux marques resteront
distinctes et joueront la synergie
la plus grande difficulté sera de faire
s'entendre deux entreprises aux cultures
assurément étrangères en albanie le
parlement a voté cet après-midi la levée
de l'immunité parlementaire du chef de
l'opposition sali berisha qui a appelé
ce matin ses partisans au sacrifice
suprême pour renverser le gouvernement
pourrait être arrêté sur place nos
envoyés spéciaux jérôme benest patrick
dissimulé
contrôle musclé aux entrées de tirana ce
18 septembre et journée nationale de
protestation de l'opposition lundi les
manifestants avaient pris les armes
aujourd'hui les forces d'intervention
urgente de la police sont sur le pied de
guerre
chaque véhicule chaque homme sont
fouillés sans ménagement 6 jours après
l'assassinât du député à gmail dari ils
sont encore des milliers dans la boue à
bas le communisme qui s'étonne qui
estiment que le pouvoir renouer avec des
pratiques d'autres choix le fils du
député assassiné est aux côtés de sali
berisha
le chef de l'opposition au même moment
son ennemi juré le premier ministre jan
o donne le la d'un vote unanime des
députés socialistes pour la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire de berisha il
est passible de la prison à vie pour
tentative d'insurrection armée dans son
bureau qu'il ne quitte plus berisha ne
se laisse pas intimider
je n'ai aucune population de seul de
continuer la bataille juge antonio
moment la levée de l'immunité
parlementaire de sali berisha ne veut
pas forcément dire que chef de
l'opposition va être arrêté dans les
heures qui viennent
peut-être les autorités albanaises
préféreront telle attente qu'il y ait un
peu moins de journalistes de la presse
internationale
ici à tirana près de belfast cinq
activistes d'irlande du nord condamné à
vie pour meurtre ont été libérée
conformément à l'accord de paix en
ulster environ 200 autres devraient
retrouver la liberté d'ici le mois de
décembre
retour en france à marseille devant les
prud'hommes le cadre de cet ingénieur
qui a refusé à quelques jours du départ
de s'installer en algérie licenciement
abusif dit l'employé les prud'hommes en
ont jugé autrement mathieu proust gérard
gallien sur le port de la ciotat il y à
un ingénieur qui déchantent
jusqu'à hier il était persuadé que les
prud'hommes lui donnerait raison
persuadé que les juges comprendrait
qu'il ait refusé d'aller travailler en
algérie
simplement parce qu'il craignait y
perdre la vie
gérard tyrrell oui quand vous regardez
large comme ça vous pensez à l'algérie
on voulait vous envoyer oui j'y pense
énormément c'est un pij a voulu
connaître du fond du coeur quoi
malheureusement avec tout ce qui se
passe il annoncé dans ce contexte actuel
j'ai refusé d'y aller je sais mais qu
est ce qu il yad autres la peur et l
aqua pour expliquer cette fleur qui la
tenaille est gérard tyrrell a rassemblé
dans un gros dossier des articles sur
l'algérie il y ajouter des textes de loi
notamment l'article 231 du code du
travail qui interdit de sanctionner un
salarié refusant une activité qu'il
estime dangereuse pour sa vie ou sa
santé
mais l'évaluation du danger c'est le
juge qui l'a fait dès qu'il s'agit
d'analyser une situation de danger qui
n'est pas très flagrante à ce moment là
effectivement l'appréciation du
magistrat peut-être une appréciation
suggérer les ex employeur de gérard
refuse de s'exprimer
leur avocat a plaidé que l'employé avait
été volontaire avant de se rétracter
compromettant ainsi les contrats de la
société avec les algériens
l'ingénieur continue de dire qu'il a eu
le choix que d'accepter ou d'être
licencié il a décidé de faire appel
l' affaire ira sans doute jusqu'à la
cour de cassation près de l'île
d'ouessant l'épave d'un cargo coulé
depuis 19 ans serait à l'origine d'un
début de pollution aux hydrocarbures
hier soir les plongeurs de la marine
nationale ont colmaté deux petites
brèches décelée sur le navire douce
écoulé du carburant de propulsion les
barrages flottants seront mises en place
par précaution autour d'un parc
d'élevage de monde
deux des trois moteurs de l'avion de la
suisse air qui s'est abîmé en mer le 3
septembre dernier ont été localisés
cette découverte pour apporter des
informations précieuses par ailleurs les
enquêteurs ont présenté pour la première
fois des films et photos réalisées par
des caméras télécommandées sur
lesquelles apparaissent des débris de la
carlingue en france le grand projet du
tgv méditerranée reliant en 3h paris à
marseille prend corps avec aujourd'hui
l'installation d'une infrastructure
pharaonique un immense viaduc de 2400
tonnes qui a pris sa place en roulant
littéralement sur l'eau romuald de bonne
offre
basket c'est un drôle d'animal un géant
d'acier de 2400 tonnes que des hommes
lilliputiens se sont mis en tête de
dompter installions furent au caire
entre les deux berges d'un fleuve
rien de plus simple en apparence mais
ici il a fallu déjouer la puissance des
eaux du rhône et la violence du mistral
impossible de construire sur place alors
les ingénieurs ont eu une idée bien
saugrenue
une fois assemblée le monstre de métal
est arrivé en roulant sur l'eau une
première réalisée par guidage
informatique à la vitesse de 200 mètres
à l'heure le système est contrôlé par
visée laser
c'est une visée laser qui nous permet
d'ajuster la trajectoire au centimètre
près toutes les informations sont
transmises à l'informatique et aux
hommes aux opérateurs bien sûr qui
pilote tout ça est ce qui nous a permis
d'accoster très vite un ouvrage d'art
sera construit tous les 600 mètres en
conciliant parfois l'inconciliable comme
ici près d'avignon
élever un double peau monumentale sur
plus de trois kilomètres
un viaduc capable de supporter le
croisement de deux rames tgv 1600 tonnes
lancé à 300 km heure le tout au coeur
d'une zone à la défense devant dans la
phase chantier jusqu'à 200 kilomètres à
l'heure c'est calculé pour résister à ce
type de vin on a également les problèmes
sismique liée à la région et on a pris
comme come stay d'études une marge très
confortable par rapport aux éventualités
sismique produit historiquement sur la
faille de nîmes des viaducs
technologique bien loin du charme du
vieux pont d'avignon est la veille de la
grande techno parade à paris et qui
devrait rassembler à l'image de berlin
des dizaines de milliers d'adeptes de la
techno je vous propose de découvrir
l'univers de la musique électronique qui
est née il ya une dizaine d'années aux
états unis au delà de l'image souvent
sulfureuse des rave parties que l'on
associe à la techno cette initiation de
ce mouvement
mouvement culturel et social symbole
d'une partie de la jeunesse avec thomas
senécal et vincent bouffartigue
les rendez-vous au clair de lune c'est
dépassé aujourd'hui à l'aube de l'an
les rendez-vous sont devenus
électronique au quartier général du
festival techno l'astre que l'on préfère
c'est le dj laurent garnier laurent
garnier fait l' étoile dans le ciel de
la techno française
et voici son producteur qui vient
vérifier les costumes de scène
j'étais un producteur heureux puisque
son poulain a vendu 200 mille
exemplaires de son dernier album vous ne
connaissez pas laurent garnier écouter
de d'énergie à l'état pur qui a dans la
techno c'est cette espèce des reproches
très très positifs de tout et sans
crainte sans angoisse etc
on essaye on expérimente et puis on voit
ce qui est bien et bien ce qui n'est pas
bien on vous passe à autre chose
je pense que c'est ça qui captive
échanges sur la planète techno rien ne
se perd tout se transforme
la recette prenez deux vinyles à 60
francs a ajouté deux platines à 3000
francs mikvé ces prêts pas besoin
d'avoir fait le conservatoire devenir
apprentis dj est à la portée de chacun
chez les disquaires on consulte aussi
les flyers pour tout savoir sur les
prochaines soirées
on les appelle les rave partys des fêtes
géantes organisées dans des usines
désaffectées ou dans la nature à cause
d'elle
la techno a longtemps fait peur mais
aujourd'hui les soirées sont officielles
100 francs c'est le prime un passeport
pour le tempo
deux personnes
le tempo c'est la sphère du dj aux
platines ce soir wario 28 ans et cinq
années de métier derrière lui le premier
travail consiste en fin de compte à
akalé la vitesse d'un disque diam
voilà mon cas ce montant fait beau
chercher la bonne vitesse dans cette
musique débarquent des états unis il ya
dix ans beaucoup lui prédisent une
carrière de météores qui tonnaient tito
morte
mais aujourd'hui la faune techno n'a
jamais été aussi nombreuses demain à
paris ils seront 200 milles à la grande
parade toute cette fin de semaine sera
marquée par les journées du patrimoine
12000 monument accessible au public dans
toute la france demain et après demain
nous avons choisi ce soir l'exemple de
ces tisseur de soie à lyon
un atelier classé que nous fait
découvrir gérard belmas la colline qui
travaille la croix-rousse fief vionnet
des tisseurs de sa majesté la soie roger
gavaggio a mis vingt ans à savoir
peindre un carré en dix minutes avec une
simple boule de coton
autodidacte virtuose roger estime
pourtant avoir fait le tour du truc
alors pour la 6ème fois il redevient
apprentis mais pas n'importe quelle
heure fait car il a choisi pour mettre
le dernier tisseur à bras eux devront
encore pour la haute couture
george matt long 85 ans toujours bonnes
mains bon pied bon oeil
pour manoeuvrer navette et canettes il
ne faut pas regarder en l'air de passer
la même chose n'avait pas passé au
travers des deux parties alors
évidemment on avait tour est passé au
travers des deux parties les deux
complices sortent deux mètres de tissus
unique chaque jour pour balmain lapidus
christian lacroix uni la riche 2000
francs le mètre en prix de revient
les quatre métiers l'ourdissoir le web
sont classés monuments historiques
ils datent du xviiie ou de 1831 la
première révolte ouvrière ou encore de
napoléon iii l'époque ça
vous faites roger est ce que c'est
difficile de devenir artiste de la tran
et de la chaîne pour un savoir faire un
que jorge ait said patiemment de
m'inculquer je trouve qu'elle a pas mal
de patience pour ça d'ailleurs mais
c'est du doigt de pied jusqu'au bout des
doigts effectivement tout est une
histoire de senti quand je vais mettre à
travailler une rythmique qui sait de
l'autre l'autre bloc georges avec les 85
ans va arriver locked up doc le floch
bon ça décourage amplement fait on
continue quand même parce que c'est très
excitant
il y a deux siècles ils étaient des
milliers à tisser s'énerver il conte
puis roger et son ancien georges ils ne
sont plus qu'une douzaine de
professionnels lyonnais de haute qualité
en quelque sorte le dernier carré ne
tient qu'à un fil
et pourtant il faudrait absolument que
ce matériau vivant est encore la vie
devant soi
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres aux
etats-unis le congrès a voté tout à
l'heure la diffusion sur les chaînes de
télévision du témoignage vidéo de bill
clinton diffusion à partir de lundi
prochain
manifestation des enseignants à paris à
l'appel du principal syndicat une
mobilisation en demi teinte avec comme
revendication davantage de moyens
tout de suite la météo nathalie ribout
et puis le point route valérie maurice
de master dont une gaffe et catherine
ceylac que reçoit mireille ballestrazzi
directeur adjoint de la police
judiciaire
je vous retrouve quant à moi demain à
des préleveurs merci de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2